foreign
Florida and talk to Mary what's up Mary
it's an honor to speak with you the
Honor's all mine what's up
well
um I have kind of a tough question
um
so should and if so how can I be a
friend to someone who is willingly
staying in an abusive marriage to a
sexual predator
one that has intentionally hurt some of
our mutual friends
do I lean in or do I lean out
question
that's a good one
um it's a good one but I think it's a
fairly simple answer tell me what you're
struggling with
sure
so I'm part of a tight-knit group of
friends a year ago we were all on
vacation together with our families
one of the husbands cornered one of the
single moms in the group and exposed
himself to her
and then
several other women of the group
admitted that he had also been touching
them inappropriately that day but they
were like so shocked and scared they
didn't know what to do immediately sure
um so this all happened while his wife
was in the Next Room usually taking care
of their baby
and then um so he was kicked out
immediately
um and then it turns out this wasn't an
isolated event so yeah this never
happens like ta-da it never works like
that yeah right yeah well it was
shocking to the rest of us but like of
course it's like you know
um so a separate victim decided to come
forward after that someone completely
separate and then so ultimately his wife
decided to stay with him and try and
make the marriage work did your friends
uh press charges see in jail no she
attempted to the the problem was there
was like you know because there wasn't
any physical
they weren't children it was his his
word against hers they just decided to
not pick it up
rejected it yeah well played D.A
idiots
so on to the next okay so then something
else happened yeah so several months
later he did it again this time to
someone they employed
another single mom we know
um and again his wife decided to stay so
she pressed charges
so that yes she attempted to as well and
they rejected it again
so there's multiple if you know somebody
at the DA's office
I you'd be amazed I called the DA's
office I'm not joking every single day
for weeks good for you
every single day good for you
um
they have bigger fish to fry I guess no
they their their job is to get sexual
predators off because this escalates
this Behavior doesn't stay static
this Behavior moves and it goes from
exposure to touching like it did in that
house and I promise you there's a wake
of women this has happened to that like
you said you said it perfectly it's so
shocking that this happens when your
buddy's like right next door and her
husband's right here that it shuts your
body down in a way that's unnerving you
think like I would never shut me down it
does it just shuts you down man and for
sure it's it's
geez Louise no this is their job this is
the fish that they need to be frying but
okay I agree so tell me what you're
struggling with
well because you know I feel like she's
being his wife right I feel like she's
being manipulated and emotionally abused
by him I feel like she is I feel like
she is opting out of your Friendship
Circle
um
period
and you can get inside her head and try
to insert yourself into her marriage
into what's going on behind closed doors
she knows
she knows or or here's the other thing
she is calling her best friends in the
world complete and utter Liars
oh no she knows it's true he admits it
yeah
good God Almighty then yes I mean he
just tells her like oh I'll never do it
again no no she is she's opted out she
has opted out here's why
um if somebody's struggling with
addiction I have some counter-intuitive
um I tend to think uh
addiction is a connection disorder so my
friends who struggle with with addiction
I lean in I don't give them money unless
we're working towards a specific thing
um I don't like it's not willy-nilly but
I lean into that
okay
um
when somebody is with a sexual predator
someone's unsafe someone's gonna going
to enact violence in our community
they're out they have opted out like I
said earlier behavior is a language they
are choosing to leave
and I would tell her
we no longer are speak for yourself I no
longer
can be in relationship with you
connected to this guy
yeah
and you get to draw that boundary and
she gets to say oh my gosh you're
abandoning me you're the worst he said
it would never happen but great cool
whenever you put up a boundary the
people who you are putting up the
boundary against will come bang on that
boundary as hard as they can to see if
it will hold
yeah and as for me in my house I don't
hang out with sexual predators
oh for sure yeah I mean I don't you know
what I mean yeah I think my heart's just
broken that that to me sounds more
realistic I don't think I'm telling you
anything you don't know
I think it's just living with the fact
that like is my best friend and
this is I have this conflict because I
have this foundational principle that I
do not let my friends do hard things
alone
and so
I'm okay but let me tell you where that
falls in on itself
yeah she didn't ask you
and so I don't let my friends do hard
things alone if they ask me
yeah but I can't insert myself into
their life if they clearly don't want me
there
um that's true and so what you're trying
to do is play God in her house and she's
saying I'm good yes and so what you have
to do is take control of your life
and that sucks man that's so
heartbreaking you said it best I love
the Heartbreak that's the greatest word
for it
yeah
because your friend doesn't want your
help she doesn't want your wisdom she
doesn't want your advice she doesn't
want anything to do with it she wants to
go on and pretend that everything's
great and I just have a little rapey
husband but it's okay
yeah horrible
I feel terrible for their child I feel
terrible for everybody involved I'm
disgusted by the police response one
fine
he said she said fine five people in the
same house over the same weekend gets
real sketchy then the next person a few
weeks later says hey this happened too
yeah now I'm losing faith in you
can I have a do you have time for a
follow-up question yeah follow up bring
it so one thing I'm just really hitting
my head against is this perspective that
she has that like he has no control over
this because he's a sexual addict
bullcrap on a stick on a pony in a box
out on the beach somewhere that's not
true great thank you
no problem keeping my pants on so you
know I don't get it but it's just
you know
um here's the deal I know I know I've
sat with people who struggle with all
sorts of forms of sexual addiction it
happens
I will even go as far to say especially
initially the impulse is very hard to
control it's real the the the kind of
like uh you have to sneeze and you can't
sneeze
or I've I got diagnosed with OCD long
ago like I need to Blink or I start
counting things it's hard when I catch
myself and I have to stop okay that's
hard I feel it it's almost like a
pressure that builds up
um
and
that is no excuse to destroy the lives
of other people so it becomes your job
if that's your impulse
to go get the care and help you need so
you stop hurting community members and
if you won't it's the police's job it's
our community's job to say you you have
exited out of our community you are no
longer allowed to be a part of this
community because you keep violating
people's sexual boundaries
that's how that goes and so I will go
with her as far as he can't control the
impulse it's a it's a it's internal
and that's where that ends because he
can control his behavior period he can
go get help period he can say I won't be
around any other people until I get this
under control period he can go check
himself into a rehabilitation Clinic
period and he's choosing not to he's
choosing to let everybody else in his
community all these other women who are
a part of his life through his wife
through his you know his child
um they get to pay the price for his
cowardice and his his unwillingness to
go get well
period
I don't know if I made myself clear
enough on that or not I I I have I have
so little patience for sexual predicting
I Predators I I
um in several of my mentors like my
professors
um Witten were lice are licensed in
working with behavioral sex
um folks who struggle with
sexual behavior disorders okay like and
so I get it it's hard it's a nightmare
and it is not permission
I mean I can't imagine walking into a
room of my wife's friends and thinking
you know what I really feel like doing
right now is taking my pants up like I
can't imagine that I I sympathize with
somebody who that's that's their body is
like do it do it do it
and you can't do that you gotta go get
help
well and it's also very predatory
behavior like who he chooses of course
it is
of course it is and there's a real big
Power Play to do that when your wife's
in the Next Room
like what are you gonna do he's in the
house every time oh you're gonna blow
the weekend up you're gonna make a big
deal in front of her
and your body goes just shuts down and
then that power I win
I got it right I'm not having that dude
no way no way but I I want to honor you
this is hard because you're losing your
good friend
I also have to say I don't talk crap
about your friend but I'm gonna going to
um at this point she has to begin to
shoulder this
she's choosing to bring a sexual
predator into these situations
she's choosing to make excuses for a
sexual predator and that makes her
complicit
that makes her a part of it
yeah that's my struggle yeah
I found out some hard things about a
friend of mine recently
um not anything like this
um and it messed me up messed me up they
just weren't who I thought they were
and um nothing illegal or anything like
that but they weren't who I thought they
were and it it hurt man
I had to sit with that
I think I tried to make excuses like I'm
trying to stop stop yeah because what
happens when you do that you compromise
you
and then that leads to that one moment
when she's like I know he said I know he
promised he won't do it but I need him
here at this thing is that cool
and you're like fine
and that happens again
that's how that happens
so this is the season when you grieve it
like mad weep cry be angry be frustrated
and I think you have to go do the right
thing
and I continue I applaud you for calling
the DA's office I think you continue to
Bang the Drum as loud as possible
all the time all the time all the time
Reach Out Reach Out Reach Out reach out
you hear any inkling that's happened
again I'm calling everybody any inkless
happening I'm calling everybody
if I see him with a group of women or I
see him with a group of kids I'm calling
it calling it out loud
thank you
I hate it hate it hate it hate this for
you hate this for everybody hate this
for her I hate this for him I hate this
for everybody I hate it
I'll say this to you listening
if you are in a relationship whether
you're close friends you're in a
romantic relationship with somebody
who's a sexual predator
and you're making excuses for them
you are
um not encouraging but allowing their
behavior
you're believing the third and fourth
and fifth and sixth time it won't happen
again it won't happen again it won't
happen again you are part of the problem
nothing changes until we change
and yes I recognize this blows up
everything you didn't blow it up the
sexual predator in your life did
all you're doing I was acknowledging the
explosion of everything
but as a community
as a guy with a wife as a guy with a
little daughter
I want us all
like my buddy Sean Ryan man he's he's
we've had some some conversations about
the sexual predator stuff I didn't even
know was out there
that kind of crap stops when we stop it
period